hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück in der today
show jetzt bin ich hier auch endlich
wieder dabei und zwar weil die letzte
folge bei mir endlich ist relativ
endlich ist wirklich relativ jetzt bin
ich hier endlich ja ich bin jetzt wieder
dabei weil letztes mal ist meine
aufnahme einfach abgepackt bzw nicht
abgesagt sondern mein internet war weg
und hier bin ich wieder gold freuen sich
so sieht man wild möchte jetzt endlich
sein haus fertig bauen glaube ich aber
anfang zumindest du warst also im
dschungel ich verstehe auch nicht mehr
ganz auf dem neuesten stand der dinge
und habe meine schützlinge besorgt
einsetzen oder so den ich kann mich mal
besuchen bikeshop mir die achtbeste gar
nicht mehr
aber du kannst unten dahingehende also
der mist fertig darstelle
die klasse schon gesungen was ist das
hab ich gesehen und hat nicht genug sein
um zu reparieren kg ich schaue jetzt nur
noch ok wo ist das überhaupt direkt beim
box links davon so noch vor dem fluss da
ist mit fackeln das in ganz vielen
fackeln geht einfach so drei blöcke erde
sind weg da geht es dann im boden rein
dann kann es ja ganz runter gehen und
das in die falle
und dann stehst dann sozusagen beide auf
fuße von denen das heißt sie könnte ich
nur nur treffen wenn du ganz viel pech
hast aber stürzt ja nicht nur ganz viel
hast ja dann kann ihr also eigentlich
nicht treffen aber manchmal auch bei der
farm von denen man sich jetzt bei der
farm von denen noch ein bisschen zurück
wieder eigentlich schon vor dem haus
links da is oder soll ich dir zeige ich
bin schon ich bin dafür
drake oder ich bin in seiner höhle
gelandet ja ja das nächste dreier weg
runter so und dann leiter weil ich finde
dass ich find s
ich schaff das alleine
sagst du schon groß nach kondition was
er denkt
ich find das willst du doch standort
nicht reingehen
ich bin ich im haus von den spielen im
haus von denen der sonne leiter die geht
nach oben
was soll denn da beim haus von
baustoffen ihrer nächsten das echt nicht
ihr seid gri vorkasse liefern da ist
schon alles weg gekriegt aber da stehen
34 könne ja und da geht's runter einfach
okay ist ein wunderschöner würde schon
eine wendeltreppe
denn den den super g auf den euro das
jedoch anders klassenleiter
ich wollte sachen dabei um das töten ja
wie
okay aber drobny keine chance mehr egal
du brauchst doch nur vier stück erstmal
oder ich wollte erstmal schon mal zwölf
holen damit ich falls es ein glücklicher
kleiner baum wird so damit nicht einmal
die ganze welt du brauchst doch vier
nehmen oder nicht genau vier ineinander
und das meist mehrmals haus werden ich
werde mir jetzt gefunden geschichte
eingehen da von ihr keine fackeln
nochmal die saftigsten oder wie
natürlich die treffer richtig oft man
also mich nicht wenn du dich richtig hin
stellt eigentlich nicht aber die stimmen
darunter und dann wenn man die weg
schlägt dann treffen die ein einer
schere sitzen kaputt surfen
können wir die koordinaten sagen von von
den weg nach haus leider nein
ja das wie gesagt ein 100 iges ist - 100
und ist 200 apps apps apps apps apps ok
reicht jetzt geht es also egal ich
wollte nochmal medienthema thema dena
und daher steckt thema den arbeit wird
auch welche geschrieben und zwar zum
beispiel der jannik bzw es super panda
thema lena was haltet ihr von leuten die
sich musik et cetera aus dem internet
illegal downloaden einfach niemand mehr
das immer schon recht genau so wenig
genauso wir hatten nur
musik runterladen oder spotify oder
sowas musik runterladen und spotify mit
skaten
da stimmt das ist natürlich schade
dann nehmen wir mal von dem was suchst
du eigentlich hier ich war unten einmal
in deiner um zu gucken kann eh nix von
der clown man warte hier bringt
organisiere ich hier in der gala und
auch noch eine seltene sachen drin weil
egal weiß der spielertrainer von quer zu
ihren wert zu mindern wie glaubt ihr
wird die welt in zirka 50 bis 100 jahren
aussehen
was ich an groß verändern was bleibt
fünf meter weiter
aber wie sieht sie aus
der grund immer noch und jetzt dann rund
nicht mehr elektrische junge da ebene
ellipse das kleine stück da mensch die
welt für eine scheibe oder nicht ja ich
total
ich habe gedacht es wäre so nähe ist in
den 50 jahren
was ist zum beispiel mit autos werden
wir immer noch mit normalen autos von
elektroautos oder führer großen autos
gesagt dafür reicht denkweise was das er
dann in richtung elektro und sowas geht
weil halt einfach kein öl und benzin
etwas mehr weil einfach die
rohstoffpreise oder wasser immer
wahrscheinlich gibt es einen krieg um
die rohstoffe oder so keine ahnung und
auf den mainzer was oder ums wasser aufs
wasser
es haben auch alex gerade so gibt es
heute schon in ansätzen bei was alex
katz spiel stand region was wir nicht
was gibt es da dann ändert wenn fluss
durch zwei länder fließt und der erste
fluss mit dem staudamm ist abkapselt das
andere land plötzlich kaum noch wasser
und gleich als frame einbruch und jetzt
rennt ein ende ich hoch und türen
automatisch gutes vorfeld gab es über
beweisen hippel er rennt einfach
seitlich hat ist auch schon mal auf das
einfach ok danke für den ganzen letzten
den ich habe auch tnt jetzt gefunden
dass er cool
danke voll nett aber die leiter hatte
ich trotzdem gern wieder okay sei alles
von dir halt gibt es die aber so weit
außerhalb gebaut und nichts war die
zerstörte ok wo solches dann half den
baum
hier landeten dass wir diese einen seite
gegeben da kann ich auf die andere seite
gehen weil hier nämlich schon bald ja
ich wollte ja extra hatte und um damit
du halt in so einem gerodeten wald ein
baumhaus hast ein bisschen nämlich nicht
mehr öko sondern bist du so mächtige
irgendwie lustig oder hatte simon ich
finde ich mal hin wo du dein baumhaus
bauen könntest ja was hier ist auch noch
nichts hier den eggeweg ich möchte ihm
zeigen
ja ich möchte dass bestimmte bestimmt
immer du hast bestimmt
jetzt kommt die man ja ich wäre ja dafür
ich werde euch hier das lied so dass sie
zu abgekapselt aus dass ein tier macht
das ist ja gut weil wir können den weg
dann hiervon so wieder hierhin machen
hier ja ok simon
jeder hier oder da unten wie groß das
werden soll weil ich würde sagen dass da
unten kommen weil popstars weit weg ja
okay machen wir hier helfen erde
wieso hast du eigentlich relativ mit
einem ich nicht wo es dann ins haus
hochgeht wir können der oma diese diese
diesen diese farben da das ist wirklich
einfach nur abgekapselt sich das aus
also das tier hatte schaufeln oder so
was für mich habt oder so oder äxte oder
sowas sehr verbunden können schaufel dem
unten und eine kiste vielleicht hätte
schon aufgegeben
april hatte kiste hier in der nähe ja
hier und da
warum ist denn also net toyoda irgendwas
kaputt gemacht
bei dir gelegt jeder sachen hin
außerdem habe ich gestern ist immer was
gegeben da ist denkt sein das heißt
ausrüstung am anfang da mal drin war
da ist er ja ich hab sie nicht mal level
jetzt einrichtung unter antwort okay
hast du mir einen gefallen tun und sich
auf die schallplatte da drauf treten
einmal und dann kanns noch weglaufen
einmal drauf treten muss nicht nur
einmal drauf treten
ich weiß ja auf mich sein vertrauen und
einmal drauf errechnete dich drauf das
reicht aber auch die platte produzieren
wäre da geht irgendwas kaputt von meinem
haus ganz viel aufbauen
ja und alles ich hoffe noch in ein haus
gelegt hast du vor deinem haus gelebt
der weg der weg ich schon kaputt genug
da er kommt auch wieder raus was
inszeniere höhlig hier
naja kommt da nicht mehr raus standen
hotspot nicht so harry potter fanclubs
grundstück verschwunden dass derart haus
da vorne ja okay dann habe ich dann mein
haus annehmen
wir sind verbündete ich hoffe mein haus
weiter macht das was für ideen du hast
krank ich kann echt krank psychopath so
ich brauche definitiv erstmals habe ich
sogar dabei erzählt das sehr schön
darauf kommen kann darauf was meiner
farm ein bisschen weg
ich habe da eine packerin gesetzt das
soll nicht so hell war vorher in ein
mensch älter ist alles beherrschen so
ich brauche und dunkles holz euro
nichts habe ich getan
wer war bitte was warum ist der erde an
meiner wand wo meine geheime kiste war
dennoch soll das
das war ich nicht täglich warst du das
echt nicht ohne ist einmal mehr die
geheime kiste dies jetzt woanders
wieso war da so viel kapital hierhin der
da war richtig viel pistone verbaut die
kiste war ja also was ist doch ja okay
mein haus wird jetzt eine pflanze ich
muss jetzt von weiteren punkt auf der
richtige weg ist ist es sehr richtig
können sie ganz viel erde geben
ich brauche lieber knochenmehl wenn du
mir knochen mir geben willst das wäre
wirklich könnte der zwölf knochenmehl
geben das wäre wirklich nett dann würde
ich dir wirklich dann könnte ich habe
gerade zwei bildest du mir dann auch
einen gefallen tun und auf eine gewisse
platte drauftreten mache ich möchte mal
was du nicht ich würde sogar 20 km und
eine schere und nun doch lieb so geht es
durch west- und nicht weil die falle ist
echt relativ lahm
was soll man denn machen aus einer
riesigen gs ausheben untergrund dass
dort viel zu lange ok also ich habe
jetzt meinen ersten baum wird jetzt hier
wachsen
ich hoffe einfach mal dass dieser baum
ja dass dieser baum gut wachsen wird
doch peter münch und 3 ja ich habe
nochmal bitte komm zu mir und und ist
eigentlich ein bisschen mal kurz kommen
für den für den regentanz also für den
knochen für den baum tanzt beim tanz ja
damit aber gut wächst könnt ihr das
könnt ihr bitte kommt kurz nimmt den
raps überhaupt noch auf man ja kleine
maps auf sicher falls ihr noch mehr
hinunter läuft einfach da vorweg ich
meine ja alle zuschauer ich habe eben
ein bisschen gefehlt musste den mann
fest ein bisschen hat ein bisschen
vorzeitig vor noch ein kleiner
rückschlag noch mehr wieder
kannst du ja sonst schon mal gar nicht
mal so schlecht weg kommt sicher sonst
so einzelne attrappen hier so ein bund
sieht man hat nämlich eine schlechte
skype vorgenommen hat bei mir auch ein
faktor drei hohlen baum ja jetzt kommt
noch mehr dazu er ist wie viele bäume
machst du denn just go macht eine brücke
zwischen in meinem haus zum eltern aber
leidet an richtig geiler ich würde sagen
alter das war richtig episch wenn wir
über so ein paar dschungel bäume hätten
und die alle so miteinander verbinden
würden das ist nur bei mir gibt's die ok
da wollen wir jetzt angehen verstanden
kann sich hier kurz kennen herunterladen
kopieren thema thema von clp auf twitter
er stellte martina habt ihr aus ihrer
was haltet ihr von ihnen weiterbaus so
schön grund weshalb er den rat ja weil
das bettchen kranke scheiße oder kranke
scheiße gut dann thema den nerv von
simon